la politique à présent c'est une époque
déroutante la france coin sur une
réforme du code du travail le royaume
uni vous le savez se sépare de l'europe
et souverainistes et les extrémistes se
frotte les mains
l'union européenne a un genou à terre
l'avenir s'annonce et moderne on le
découvre rétrograde
qu'en pense au juste françois bayrou
l'européen le fédéraliste le modéré le
président du modem est notre invité bon
soir françois bayrou soit merci d'être
avec nous dans 64 minutes sur tv5 monde
commençons par l'actualité et ce qui se
passe en en turquie après paris
bruxelles orlando abidjan un village
libanais aussi avant-hier et donc à
nouveau istanbul il faudrait du temps
pour citer toutes les villes victimes de
ce type d'attentât comment endiguer le
phénomène mondial qu'est le terrorisme
selon vous en travaillant ensemble
le seul moyen de bâtir des défense
sérieuse c'est des échanges
d'informations sérieux manière de
repérage sérieux solide dans lequel on
travaille en confiance dans lequel on
échange des informations dans lequel
tous nos toute notre capacité de
surveillance s'exerce ensemble il faut
comprendre une chose c'est que pour les
terroristes
les frontières sont des protections
quand j'entends des gens qui disent on
va on va on va sortir de l'europe pour
se défendre soi même c'est gilles je
ressens un aveuglement absolument
incroyable parce que si vous avez une
frontière et si les polices des deux
côtés de la frontière ne communique pas
il suffit de passer la frontière pour
être tranquille on sait bien ça dans ma
région
au pied des pyrénées
parce que le thé à mouvement qui était
un mouvement
qui usé des violences et assassiné des
bombes et faisait sauter des bombes
terroristes
ce mouvement là avaient toutes ses bases
de repli
de l'autre côté des pyrénées à quelques
kilomètres en france et là évidemment
comme n'y avait pas d' échanges avec les
politiques et le jour où on a décidé de
faire il a été décidé de faire des vrais
échanges avec la police espère entre
polices espagnole et française de mettre
le travail en commun ce journal le taa
été réduit et même a été obligé de
déposer les armes et donc tant qu'on ne
comprend pas que c'est là le travail en
commun la coopération le l'intimité
entre entre tous ceux qui sont menacés
qui nous permettra non pas de supprimer
mais de faire reculer les menaces au
comprendra rien françois bayrou on a
d'un côté des terroristes qui disent
vous nous bombarder donc on commet des
attentats chez vous dans vos pays en
occident et on a des états qui
répliquent en disant vous commentez des
attentats chez nous donc on vient vous
bombardez comment sortir de ce cercle
cercle infernal
bon c'est un très grand sujet de s'en
vouloir employer de trop grands mots de
civilisation n'est ce pas ce qu'ils
veulent soumettre l'ensemble de la vie
humaine et des sociétés à 1 une autorité
religieuse considéré comme infaillible
ceux là sont en rupture avec la
conception qui est la nôtre d'une
société pluraliste dans laquelle on
respecte les opinions les convictions
les philosophies et les religions
différentes là est la grande ligne de
partage et cette ligne de partage
elle mérite qu'on la défende le
c'est plus qu'une dictature n'est ce pas
c'est le faire peser sur toutes les vies
humaines et sur toute la vie humaine
l'autorité sans partage de gens qui
prétendent savoir ce que dit dieu et
vous voyez bien à quel point il y à là
quelque chose qui est une terrible
atteinte à la liberté humaine
or il ya qu un combat qui vaille c'est
le combat de la liberté 6 jouera
quasiment après le break site françois
bayrou les 27 dirigeants de l'union
européenne se sont réunis aujourd'hui
sans le premier ministre britannique
david cameron
ils veulent une nouvelle impulsion au
projet européen qu'elle doit être selon
vous être aujourd'hui cette impulsion
alors il faut deux choses premièrement
il faut une clarification aucun projet
ne peut être fait si on ne voit pas
clair dans la manière dont les uns et
les autres vont être organisées si par
exemple se prolonger pendant des
semaines et des mois
le brouillard autour d'eux qu'est ce qui
va se produire en grande bretagne pour
la grande bretagne
ça serait catastrophique pour tout le
monde donc il faut une clarification et
de ce point de vue là j'espère se dit
j'espère avec quelques brûlant st
j'espère que les responsables de l'union
européenne vont être capables de
d'exiger la clarification
sans la reporter à la scène septembre en
l'occurrence le prochain sommet oui
c'est pas parce qu'il est au sommet qui
a clarification et qui a rien à voir
voilà donc moins un la clarification 2
c'est très simple il faut sortir de
l'ambiguïté qui assure l'union
européenne pour les uns l'europe c'est
un marché c'est ce que voulaient les
anglais en fin de
les britanniques le l'idée que le seul
objet de l'union européenne c'est le
commerce et cette idée est une idée à
mon sens terriblement insuffisante et
terriblement frustrante pour les peuples
le fait que l'union européenne se soit
concentrée sur ce sujet a été une part
terrible de son affaiblissement
parce que les gens sont d'immigrés à
quoi ça sert y font d'énormes sur des
normes c'est à dire des règles sûres il
invente des normes sur les concombres
disaient les zones les opposer ou sur
les moteur de tondeuse à gazon sur le
niveau sonore des aspirateurs je dis pas
que ce soit des choses inutiles puisque
si on veut faire du commerce il faut en
effet que ça réponde aux mêmes
non ce n'est pas que ça règle mais c'est
pas l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est que
nous sommes des nations dont la taille
ne nous permet pas de répondre aux
grands problèmes du monde
ceux qui vous écoutent ils sont plongés
dans les grands problèmes du monde
ce vos auditeurs et téléspectateurs ils
savent très bien ce qui se passe les
grands problèmes du monde on a évoqué ce
qui se passait au moyen-orient c'est la
puissance qui a des problèmes aussi de
la chine c'est l'immense
société au pluriel de l'inde sait ce qui
se passe sur le continent américain nord
et sud et les immenses risque qui a
autour de tout ça l'europe elle est
faite pour ça elle est faite pour
s'occuper de l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
pour permettre à chacune des nations
qu'il s'agit pas de faire disparaître
heureusement que nous sommes français on
peut difficilement trouver plus amoureux
de la france que je le suis heureusement
qu'il ya des allemands qui à des
italiens qui lie à montrent toutes ces
nations existent et il faut cependant
qu'elle décide de travailler ensemble
pour sauver ou pour promouvoir
l'essentiel ensemble elles seront fortes
séparer elles seront faibles
alors c'est ça l'europe donc il faut
recentrer l'europe
je suis sûr que tous ceux qui vous
écoutent le sable il faut recentrer
l'europe autour de l'essentiel
mais parmi ceux qui nous écoutent
françois bayrou et qu'une regarde il y
as peut-être aussi de manière de lire ce
break zid certains disent que les
britanniques sont tombés dans un piège
de politique intérieure david cameron le
premier notamment d'autres y voient
l'expression d'un peuple souverain
quelle est votre vision des choses vous
l'européen convaincu
je suis non européens qui aiment l'idée
que les peuples sont souverains mais
pour un pays comme la france
même comme la france alors je parle pas
des petits pays européens qui ont sont
ce problème multiplié par huit par 10
pour un pays comme la france il n'y a de
souveraineté que si nous sommes capables
de créer la puissance qui nous fera
écouter du reste du monde
l'idée qu' on peut être souverain tout
seul est une idée qui n'a plus cours
aujourd'hui
le si vous êtes en face de la chine et
que la chine veut vous imposer des lois
commerciales
si vous êtes tout seul vous êtes un
microbe vous ne posez pas et les chinois
et crainte de rire
in petto s'ils ne montrent pas à
l'extérieur mais naturellement il se
moque de vous si vous êtes une puissance
qui comporte plusieurs centaines de
millions d'habitants et une industrie
puissante alors vous pouvez vous faire
respecter
là est la seule véritable souveraineté
souveraineté étatique mais souveraineté
du peuple est ce que les français selon
vous doivent se prononcer pour ou contre
le maintien de la france vous savez bien
que cette question posée comme ça n'a
pas de sens
le le le la france a été créatrice de
l'union européenne on peut proposer un
autre équilibre pour l'union européenne
et le faire adopter par référendum ce
jour là mais si la france se retrouve
seul on est criminel pas de référendum
sur un éventuel fera exit alors sûrement
enfin l'idée qu' on pourrait envisager
que la france sorte de l'union
européenne est une idée suicidaire en
revanche que des dirigeants nouveaux
ayant une vision de l'avenir sachant ce
qu'ils veulent
propose aux français une feuille de
route soumettent aux français un mandat
pour dire ce qu'on doit faire dans
l'avenir
par exemple pour réintroduire le peuple
des citoyens dans la boucle des
décisions à prendre
alors ça je prends ça aussi selon vous
nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande ont
échoué en la matière alors nicolas
sarkozy porte une responsabilité très
importante parce qu'il a fait le traité
de lisbonne est le traité de lisbonne
c'était une manière de court circuiter
pour pas dire autre chose
le choix qui s était exprimé au
référendum moi je pense que quand une
décision a été prise par le peuple tout
entier il faut il n'y a que le peuple
tout entier qui puisse la corriger l
actuel président français et françois
hollande 20 pendant quatre ans il a rien
dit et donc moi je croyais que françois
hollande était un européen dans la
lignée de jacques delors d'ailleurs
c'est comme ça qu'il avait commencé sa
vie politique
et puis je me suis aperçu que de
l'avenir de l'europe ne parlait jamais
aux français est ce qu'il ne faut pas
aussi cesser cet élargissement sans fin
dit certains pour éviter ce désamour des
citoyens européens envers l'europe la
semaine dernière sur ce plateau nicolas
dupont aignan souverainiste disait qu'il
était pour un retour à quatre états
nations par exemple quel est votre avis
à ce sujet combien une europe à combien
tu
vous êtes - 10h27 vous vous souviendrez
que j'étais un des auteurs de la formule
qui disait approfondissement avant
élargissement vous souviendrez que je
suis de ceux qui ont le plus fortement
défendu l'idée que faire entrer la
turquie au sein de l'union européenne
s'étaient prendre un risque mais
absolument déraisonnable mensongers et
que j'avais à l'époque contre moi le
pouvoir de droite et l'opposition de
gauche
les deux étaient opposés à ce que nous
défendions donc je suis hostile aux
élargissements perpétuel et inconsidéré
c'est de cela que nous avons souffert et
que nous continuons à souffrir pour le
reste la question va se poser aux
européens de savoir quelle europe ils
veulent s'ils veulent une europe
uniquement du commerce c'est le cas de
la périphérie d'un certain nombre de
pays qui ne partage pas l'idée d'un
d'une volonté politique commune et
partagée des nations européennes ou des
états nations européens cela en effet
devons trancher entre et probablement y
at il deux projets et donc il y aura une
europe à deux cercles une serre qu un
cercle qui est celui de la zone euro qui
partageant une monnaie devra partager
une volonté et un cercle périphériques
de ceux qui se contentent au fond de
deux d'accepter les mêmes règles
commerciales et juridiques
mais eux ne font pas une puissance
politique qui puisse être respecté dans
le monde
il faut une zone commerciale et chacun
pour soi je ne suis pas pour cette
solution
je suis pour qu'on fasse ensemble une
europe qui s'occupe enfin de l'essentiel
merci beaucoup françois bayrou d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le président du mouvement
démocrate français le modem vous avez
été ministre sous la présidence de
jacques chirac
vous le savez le musée du quai branly
fait c
dix ans et sept établissements culturels
porte désormais le nom de l'ancien
président français sa fille claude
chirac se confie dans votre grande
édition tout de suite c'est l'invité de
patrick simonin rester avec nous